how did she think we did with the snoop
song oh my God my nose ready okay I'm
okay with you lying
that's no no this is my go-to karaoke
song so I want to know I didn't come
here it's a lie you should be a coach on
that voice I came here to tell the truth
yeah I'm gonna hear the truth okay well
he really has notes written down well
give me a lot of confidence projection
because you're on live instruments
there's live drums and you have to have
a different level of like confidence to
be on top of those and be in a pocket
you know I'm saying and the go-go world
we really know we really have you know
packs you were really in your pocket oh
I was obviously I'm not on my Bimmer
pocket oh so you can shift it a lot we
know usually I'm way I'm like Willie
Nelson I'm like way behind the beat
usually who's Willie Nelson George
choking I smoked with him outside got a
little one at the end I was like oh you
can't help yourself I can't like she
couldn't help it she ran it Jenna dudes
don't sound like that she had to make it
me but that's what's happening that's
what telling them okay
I said cowbell went in for this snoot
moment for a long time and it shows
because he was all point he was ready
he's focused yeah any and the last thing
is um can I sign up because the
demographic will be these guys we're
going to come up with I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this